Finally, if this cute
little street performance
doesn't warrant a dollar,
I don't know what does.
[harmonica playing]
♪ ♪
(Daniel)
Is it considered
child molestation
if that finger baby
beats you off?
Who's crazier,
the creepy homeless guy
or the person letting
a creepy homeless guy
touch his face?
You realize everything
touching your face
has been in his butthole.
Five years ago,
that guy moved to New York
to be a musician.
I can't in good conscience
let that finger baby
stay with such a weirdo.
That's why I illegally
adopted him.
Warning: single parent life.
Ugh!
Every day
is Take Your Kid to Work Day.
That's [bleep] stupid.
Language!
Not in front of the finger baby.
Sorry.
Come on, finger baby.
Come on.
Good. There you go.
There you go.
I'm gonna let go.
Oh, finger baby fell!
Come on.
Help!
My finger baby's locked
in a hot car!
Ahh, this hurts!
Oh, sorry.
He refuses to drink formula.
It's okay.
I have two of my own.
Oh!
Made the mistake
of vaccinating finger baby.
Now he can't blink.
Good night.